panel is a highly available externally
consistent and globally distributed
database creating an instance and
connecting your application to Cloud
spanner is pretty straightforward but
let's say you want to migrate your
application from another database into
Google call spanner let's see how we do
that using hoverbridge Harbor Bridge Is
An Open Source tool for migrating data
and schema to Cloud spanner Harbor
Bridge connects to the source database
and inherently in a single unified
interface sets up and orchestrates bulk
load and incremental data and schema
streams to cloud storage processes with
data flow and writes it all to Cloud
span and what's new with Harbor Bridge
now you ask minimal downtime migration
improved schema assessment and
recommendations gcloud integration for
easy setup and access of Harbor Bridge
web and on top of all that now you can
do terabyte scale data migration which
was previously not possible in our demo
today we'll be migrating data and schema
from mySQL database to Cloud spanner
the database application will be
migrating is a near real-time wall by
wall stream of Cricut data and
calculation of Target score for Team 2
in case the second Innings of the
cricket match is interrupted by rain or
other circumstances and not continued
thereafter this is calculated using the
famous Duckworth Lewis method and we are
updating it for every ball of second
Innings that way at any given point we
would know what the winning Target is in
case the match is interrupted let's see
how we perform this migration with
Harbor Bridge execute these two commands
from your Google Cloud convention and
you will be able to launch hoverbridge
on the web
your Harbor Bridge web application is up
and running
before we connect to the database
remember to enable your data stream and
data flow apis
finally it's time to see how Harbor
Bridge is doing the migration from MySQL
to Cloud spanner three modes of
connecting connected database with
database details load database Dom or
load session file we'll choose the first
method connect to database
choose the database engine which is
MySQL
provide the hostname port username
password
database name and hit connect
and in the configure schema page you can
actually see the schema structure and
objects from MySQL and the draft version
of the same in spanner
the spanner draft version of configure
schema is actually the workspace where
we'll perform edits for the suggestions
and recommendations provided by Harbor
Bridge for the schema in this case the
icons that you see to the left of table
names indicate
the level of complexity required for the
conversion changes for the specific
table in this case standard DLS resource
table requires a high complexity
conversion change whereas all the other
tables require minimal conversion
changes
let's select a specific table
and in here
heading over to this panel section you
see the warnings these columns will
consume most Origins banner and also it
allows you to edit the specific columns
data types A different primary key if
needed and make the schema changes
save and convert it lets me validate and
review the ddl before I confirm
conversion
schema changes saved successfully
click prepare migration it's almost time
the migration mode is schema and data
migration type is low downtime migration
Target Cloud spanner instance
setup source connection profile
same as the case with Target connection
profile and hit migrate
everything else is taken care
automatically under the hood by Harbor
Bridge wait for a few minutes until you
see the message schema migration
completed successfully on the same page
migration completed successfully let's
get into the spanner instance to check
if the tables are all migrated
get to the database
go to the tables section and yes we do
have the tables from MySQL migrated over
to Cloud spanner now for the most
interesting part
streaming in near real time ball to ball
second Innings match data into my SQL
table for this I've written a cloud
functions function in Java that kicks
off
the data streaming
this function also calculates the
Duckworth Lewis Target score and updates
that into the MySQL table DLS
so as you can see it has already started
updating to my SQL table and you can see
the maximum Target so far it is still in
progress but in the meantime
we can go to clouds panel and check the
total count of Records which is
continuously increasing as well
once you've completed the bulk
validation and incremental load
validation click end migration on the
same page of hubbridge migration
at this point we are approaching the
downtime period of the migration once
data validation is complete stop rights
to the source database wait for any
incremental right to catch up between
the source and Cloud spanner table
this can be done by just validating the
records for most recent updates in this
panel table just like we did right now
with the Duckworth Lewis Target score
calculation
once they are in sync switch your
application to point to Cloud spanner
database perform smoke tests and cut
over the traffic to source
that marks the end of the period of
downtime
finally click the cleanup button in the
Harbor Bridge tool to remove the
migration jobs that were created